resuelve la ecuación 2x cuadrada más 375
y la buena noticia que te tengo es que
la x la podemos despejar fácilmente de
esta ecuación si nosotros lo que hacemos
son operaciones elementales vamos a
poder obtener las raíces de esta
ecuación cuadrática así que antes que
nada déjame escribir aquí de nuevo la
ecuación y me queda 12 x cuadrada más 3
igual a 75 y ahora si lo que quiero es
despejar al x cuadrada porque fíjate que
en esta ocasión no tenemos a x cuadrada
ya una x a la primera potencia por lo
tanto como primer paso voy a restar 3 de
ambos lados de la ecuación y me queda 2x
cuadrada este 3 con este 13 van y
después 75 menos tres es 72 y ahora como
quiero despejar x cuadrada me estorba
este 2 que tengo aquí por lo tanto lo
que voy a hacer es fijarme que este 2
está multiplicando el x cuadrada y por
lo tanto voy a dividir ambos lados de la
ecuación entre 2 2 entre 2 se van
me da 1 y entonces del lado izquierdo de
la ecuación solamente me queda x
cuadrada y 72 entre 2 media 36 la mitad
de 72 es 36 perfecto
y ahora lo único que me falta hacer es
pasar este cuadrado que yo tengo aquí en
la equis cuadrada pero si yo quiero
pasar un cuadrado del otro lado de la
ecuación lo paso con superación
inversión y superación inversa es la
raíz cuadrada entonces le puedes sacar
la raíz cuadrada del lado izquierdo de
la ecuación me va a quedar equis y le
voy a sacar raíz cuadrada del otro lado
de la ecuación pero recuerda que cuando
saco la raíz cuadrada tengo dos raíces
una positiva y una negativa por lo tanto
x es igual a más y menos la raíz de 36 y
deja mejor ponerlo abajo para que quede
mucho más claro voy a ponerlo aquí x es
igual a más o menos la raíz de 36 que es
6 y ojo ya tenemos dos raíces una raíz
positiva es decir x 1 es igual a 6 y una
raíz negativa que es x 2 igual a menos 6
ya tengo las dos raíces de esta ecuación
cuadrática ahora mi pregunta es serán
realmente estas raíces pues nada nos
cuesta verificar que realmente si sean
estas raíces así que voy a sustituir al
6 primero para ver si x1 igual a 6 va a
cumplir con la ecuación con la que
empezamos y dice 6 al cuadrado 36 x 272
más 375 perfecto si cumple y si pongo
menos 6
dar lo mismo porque menos 6 al cuadrado
también es 36